what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm gonna be reacting to some
fresh
and fit clips this one is called
you are a simp and here is why i'm
actually not even really sure what a
simp is but i hear guys use this term a
lot so
i'm pretty excited to learn
more and more every day before i start
do not forget
to leave a like a comment and hit that
subscribe button
guys i'm getting so close to 15 000.
i've been i've been talking about this
for like a week but if you
if you got a second just hit the
subscribe button
okay guys tomorrow game you are assuming
here from unplugged lifestyle today
we're going to talk about the top three
scent behaviors
that men exhibit towards women let's get
into it
so first let's define what is a synth
obviously in the sphere there's many
definitions for this
but i'm going to give you my nice simple
definition since i got the awesome
slogan
transform and sims to pimps baby so this
is how i define it a simp is a guy that
doesn't put any type of value on his
attention
resources or money towards a woman and
gives it freely without her
reciprocating on her end example
i pay for a chick's only fan
subscription
knowing i am never going to meet her or
date her
or ever see her in a romantic sense i'm
simply paying
to observe her body in some weird way
knowing that i'm never going to meet her
that makes me a simp that's a very
generic way to explain it but i'm going
to talk about the top three cent
behaviors
that men exhibit in 2020 let's get into
it number three okay and we're gonna go
we're gonna count this down from
least worst to worst well they're all
terrible but whatever you guys get the
point spending time and attention on a
girl that doesn't like you guys
you've all been there a girl basically
you've been talking to her for a while
maybe you guys went to school together
she's like your high school push or
college crush whatever it is
and then you go in there for the kiss
and then she's like
denied and she basically tells you like
i don't see you like that
we're just friends or let's not ruin
this friendship
you lost okay cause let me tell you guys
something the girl doesn't put you in
the friend zone you put yourself in the
friend zone you understand because
here's the thing when you meet a chick
you need to quickly escalate and see
where she stands with you if she likes
you
cool she's going to allow you to do you
guys not believe in
friends is that not a thing on here
physically escalate okay i remember
seduction takes two people
if she doesn't she's immediately gonna
stop you
okay and say something where she's going
to gracefully let you down we're just
friends or i don't see you like that
what she really means is
translation i don't find you that
attractive sexually but
i enjoy your free attention continue to
be my friend and give me that boyfriend
treatment
while i completely abstain from giving
you what you want which is
sexual attention number two spending
money
on a girl that you either are not
romantically involved with
or you're getting very how do i say this
miniscule amounts of sex from this is a
big one a lot of guys leave with their
wallet
and basically think money is the end-all
be-all but let me tell you guys
something if you have money but you have
zero game
you're probably gonna end up simping
because a lot of guys leave with their
wallet
and quite frankly girls don't respect
you when you leave with your wallet you
tell a chick hey baby
this is what i say it's not about money
guys always think girls
are just after your money and there are
some girls that are
but like a guy could win the lottery and
i guarantee
that his like the way he is with girls
isn't gonna
improve i know we just met but i'll take
you to turks and caicos islands and
we'll travel or whatever it may be
she's not gonna respect you that's the
equivalent to you well because she
doesn't know you
so if you like come out like throw in
like
free vacations and like trips that some
girl you don't even know like that's
kind of weird
meeting a chick at the club saying hey
you're hot come with me to the bathroom
and then you smash her out in the stall
or whatever right
no condom of course ew
oh my god you and the next thing you
know she's trying to tell you oh will
you be my boyfriend
more than likely you're probably gonna
say uh no uh no thank you
because you're gonna be repulsed by her
giving you the sex quickly right that's
exactly how women feel
when you openly offer your money and or
resources to her and she hasn't earned
it women
have to earn your money and resources
you understand when you lead with the
wallet
she might take it she's going to
absolutely well because it seems like
you just
do that for everyone so it makes you
come off like desperate
to take that money from you but she
ain't gonna respect you and then more
importantly she's gonna leverage her
sexuality against you
for more money she's basically gonna
suck you dry
and give you the least amount of
required sexual attention that you
desire
to continue to get money and that's why
you end up getting starfish sex
no sex or maybe not even a kiss i've
seen guys pay girls
two thousand dollars a week and not even
like kiss her bro like what
are you dumb like
what too grand they're what
insert six nine sound effect here like
are you
how i never had that kind of opportunity
stupid okay anyway and then number one
spending
a combination of time and or money
slash attention this is the reality men
want sex
women want attention it's a battle
between the two genders to leverage
the commodity they have against the
other sex
in return for their commodity for
example women
leverage their sexuality to get time
attention and resources from men
and men leverage their attention and or
resources to get it
sex from women guess who's winning this
battle women
like by far most guys freely give their
attention
time and resources to women that quite
frankly don't deserve it and have not
earned it this is why you guys want to
hear a truth bomb
most women don't respect most men i'm
going to say that again
most women what do you guys define as
respect because it really seems like
that the only way you can respect
someone
in his mind is literally to sleep with
them
but how like you can't have guy like
friends
especially attractive ones don't respect
most men as a matter of fact
you guys are invisible to these chicks
the only way you're going to put respect
on your attention time and resources is
when you make it
scarce and making it an earned commodity
from the woman because let me tell you
guys something
she will sit there and take your
attention your money
your resources and your time as much as
you allow it
to happen this is why i always say when
you're in the friend zone it's your
fault
not the girl's fault because you weren't
smart enough to understand
that your commodity is attention her
commodity is sex if she can't give you
that
it's done you don't talk to her no more
simple as that guys and the only way
you're going to be able to do that
exert that boundary that you're not
going to sit there and let a girl
use you is you need to talk to what a
lot of girls you got to work volume guys
working volume eliminates one itis which
eliminates
simpin which will give you what an
abundance mindset when you have an
abundance mindset
you treat women as expendable
commodities and guess what guys let me
tell you something
women surprise surprise treat men as
expendable commodities oh why are we
here misogynist what are you talking
about how dare you i'm speaking facts
you wanna know why
this is why she doesn't text you back is
why she flakes on dates that's why she
leaves you on scene on instagram
this is why she makes excuses to meet up
etc
if women weren't so flaky and fickle
there would be
no need for channels like this hell i'm
a fitness trainer man and i just started
giving data advice because
so many guys are having problems with
this stuff and it's it keeps how do i
get it backward how do i talk to her oh
she did this and that
her man listen man stop being dumb
if you're not getting what you want you
kick her to the curb and you move on to
the next girl
getting women is a numbers game this is
why so many
this is true i learned that in sales to
be honest
like i agree with that guys struggle
because they don't understand that
a lot of volume is required in order to
maintain an abundance mindset when you
have an abundance mind
plus you have no idea what like girls on
the other end like are looking for so it
could be something that literally has
nothing to do with you
you're not going to simp on women you
are going to treat them just like they
treat us as expendable commodities and
move on to the next girl
women naturally have an abundance
mindset see i feel like because of like
he lives in like the fast life like he
is like in the most expensive like clubs
with like the richest guys and like the
hottest girls whatever
i people like that have a very different
like
very almost negative outlook on life
because
the girls around them are just like gold
diggers you as the man
have to earn it with that said guys
don't forget to get my free ebook
unplayed okay don't care anymore um
yeah i don't really have anything else i
guess i'm learning every
more and more every day what a simp is
it seems like you really can't have any
female friends
which is kind of weird to me but let me
know in the comments if you guys agree
or disagree
um don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and like the video while you're
at it i'm going to talk to you guys
next time